good morning good afternoon good evening
depending on where you are in the world
thank you for registering for the
webinar today's presentation vitamin D
optimizing pain management will be
presented by dr. Linda Rapson dr. Robson
is a graduate of University of Toronto
and a former general practitioner dr.
Robson has 39 years of experience
integrating acupuncture into Western
medicine for many years for private
practice has been comprised mainly of
complex cases about 90% of which
involved chronic pain she's been a
lecturer and examiner with the
acupuncture Foundation of Canada
Institute for many years and his
executive president of the AFC
you
hi since 1992 dr. Robson has been
consultant to the acupuncture clinic at
Toronto Rehabilitation Institute
Lyndhurst Center a University of Toronto
affiliated Hospital specializing in the
rehabilitation of individuals with
spinal cord injuries she is an adjunct
scientist at Toronto rehab and his
principal investigator of a multicenter
randomized clinical trial on acupuncture
for neuropathic pain post spinal cord
injury
dr. Robson chaired the complementary and
integrative medicine section of the
Ontario Medical Association and was
president of the Ontario society of
physicians for complementary medicine
from their inception in 1999 until 2010
since 1997 she has studied the impact of
nutritional supplements and diet on
chronic pain and spearheaded the
development of a two-part course
nutrition for docs that was presented
through the Department of Community and
Family Medicine at the University of
Toronto dr. Robson will be taking
questions at the end of her presentation
we would encourage you to type your
questions in in the lower left hand
corner of your screen in the text box
text box under QA
with that is now my pleasure to
introduce dr. linda raphson
good day and welcome to this lecture I
hope that you're going to get some value
from it as you've heard I've been
interested in nutrition for the last
long time many years and over the last
ten years or so I've particularly
focused on vitamin D and that's what I
want to talk to you about today
before I begin I have to disclose to you
that my received an honorarium from the
asuras ins on this topic too in 2011 and
12 and expect to receive one for this
presentation in this talk I want to
present to you evidence that low vitamin
D levels can be the cause or an
aggravating factor for pain in a
significant proportion of the population
and this is goes undiagnosed much of the
time I also want to demonstrate that
having it be an understanding of what
our patients blood levels are of vitamin
D gives us the evidence to actually make
a diagnosis of vitamin D deficiency as a
reason for their their problem that
nobody can sort out that's something
that it happens once in a while you see
somebody who has symptoms that defy
diagnosis all blood tests are normal
nobody can figure it out and sometimes
this is what it is and then we can
monitor their improvement now I'm old
enough that when I was a kid
vitamin D was called the sunshine
vitamin and that was I think in order to
try and convince us that cod liver oil
didn't taste as bad as we thought it did
because we had to start taking it in the
fall when swims for autumn as you
probably say in many parts of the world
not fall and we we had to take it all
winter so our bones would be healthy we
make vitamin D in our skin as you know
when ultraviolet be like in
rocks with 70 high D hydro cholesterol
to produce vitamin D now one of the
thing that people have to understand
this only happens when the Sun is that
greater than a 45-degree angle to the
horizon in Toronto where I live in
Canada at forty three point four
latitude north and we're pretty far
south actually we're well below the the
49th parallel so we're on a level with
Northern California well we can only
make vitamin D here in our skin from
April to about September and we have to
go out in the Sun in the middle of the
day it has to be pretty much over our
heads the rule of thumb is if your
shadow is longer than then you are at
all you're not making vitamin D if you
happen to be light-skinned as I am you
may be able to make ten thousand some
people say twenty thousand units of
vitamin D in 20 minutes when you expose
your body to the Sun in the summertime
if you wear sunscreen it doesn't work
even with a protection factor of eight
it locks about 95% of vitamin D
production you're going to be hearing a
lot about 25 hydroxy D but that's a
short form for you know 25 hydroxy
vitamin D it's the circulating form of
vitamin D that's stored in fact that's
why we can measure it because it's
stored the half-life is actually three
weeks I made a mistake on this slide and
I have here two months but it's it's
three weeks whatever it is the point is
that you can't go through the entire
winter time without taking vitamin D
supplements and that's why we have to
test you or we should test you to see
what your blood loan is deficiency is
far more important more common the
darker a person's skin is it can take
six to ten times longer to produce
vitamin D it's depending on the darkness
of your skin that's very important in in
my community because we have people from
all around the world in Toronto of all
shades of darkness tonight I don't think
they're told when they get off the
airplane that they better get on to
vitamin D but it would be a really good
idea the prevalence of deficiency goes
up as you go farther from the equator
either north or south of course it's
worth when people are shut-in they don't
go out and it's worse than people who
cover their bodies while they're
outdoors food is not much help to us the
only food that really has very much B in
it is fatty fish and if you were to eat
fatty fish enough fatty fish to take
care of your vitamin D needs you'd be in
real trouble with the condition that a
lot of the fish in this world variants
some medications a lot of medications
actually interfere with the metabolism
of vitamin D and that has to be taken
into account I'm going to be giving you
a very good reference paper on that I'm
defining deficiency as lower than 75
nanomoles per liter or 30 nano grams
familiar for the Americans the optimum
level that I'm referring to I prefer to
take the position that the levels that
are reached when one gets all of one Sun
from the vitamin D from the Sun is it's
what is optimal to what mother nature
intended and there are studies that show
in farmers and in in lifeguards and so
on that there's a range of about 130 to
200 animals which is 50 to 280 nanograms
per liter milliliter and that's when I
when I am saying optimum there's a lot
of contention about this and how high it
should go so what we I don't have time
to go into that to a great extent this
on this discussion but I'll tell you
what my personal experience is there are
benchmark numbers to remember depending
on which system you're using animals or
nanograms in animals it's 25 50 and 75
and in nanograms 10 20 30
the first number 25 and 10 below both
numbers rickets is possible deformity of
bone
and osteomalacia we're bonus soft and
there's pain involved below 50 or 20
it's associated with chronic both levels
are associated with chronic pain and
below 75 which is 39 in grams per
milliliter there's an increased risk of
fracture and they the experts on that
around the world seem to agree on that
when it comes to the safety issue this
is something that has been plaguing the
movement to get vitamin D yet accepted
more widely because it is possible to
have toxicity of vitamin D but it's
extraordinarily rare
the Institute of Medicine gave a
published a report in 2010 and they
describe what they are now referring to
as the upper level which really means
the safe level but that doesn't matter
who you know no problem you can take
that much this used to be called the no
adverse event level and they're setting
it now at four thousand international
units per day and this is from the ages
9 to 70 so it's a wide range once you
get to b9 you're fine you should you can
take the same levels as an adult what
really happened at the IOM we were told
by one of the members of the pavilion
committee was that they hired an expert
to ask what is the safe level he told
them 25 thousand international units per
day is safe they thought that was that
seemed a little bit too high to tell the
public and of course they have to be
responsible in that regard so they
decided that they would make it ten
thousand however there's a formula
that's applied to this number which
guarantees that no one ever has had a
problem at that level and so that's how
it became four thousand but toxicity I
repeat is exceedingly rare and it's
defined by the presence of hypercalcemia
high levels of serum calcium if you look
at the
reference ranges published by the
Institute of Medicine and in Canada
Health Canada has adopted these you'll
see three columns and the age groups and
the three columns are the estimated
average requirement and the recommended
dietary allowance the only one I think
anybody really needs to paint a whole
lot of attention to is the column for
the upper level intake which I just
mentioned and they're saying 1000 is
safe for infants from 0 to 20 to about 6
months 1,500 from 6 to 12 months 2500 1
to 3 years 4 to 8 years three thousand
my grandchildren that has to tell you
have been on three or four thousand a
day since they were very very young the
reference range now let's clarify this
the international units that we use here
in Canada or SI units define it define
the range in in nano moles per liter and
the range is 75 to 250 the gravimetric
units that are still used by the
Americans are 30 to 100 nanograms per
milliliter that's the difference and she
convert from nanograms per milliliter to
nano moles per liter you multiply by 2.5
so you have to be alerted to this when
you're reading papers on vitamin D
anything to do with vitamin B blood
levels always look for the units for the
reference range in this study also
always look to see how the authors are
defining deficiency or insufficiency
because that's critical to understanding
the conclusions that they draw from the
studies this is some data this graph
depicts data from my practice this is
the 25 hydroxy D levels from 300
consecutive patients with pain with
chronic pain those on the left side had
pain that had lasted more than six
months six months up to 20 years in fact
those on the right had pain of less than
six months duration
the blood test was done in the summer
months on these people but the first
time I took this blood and the redline
is set at 75 nanomoles per liter as you
can see there was a statistically
significant difference between the two
groups now this this graph is represents
those whose blood was tested in the
winter months there was no statistical
significance not that statistical
difference in that group because
virtually everyone was below the line
this is circumstantial evidence that
there is a higher risk of vitamin D
deficiency with longer standing chronic
pain and then the question becomes one
of cause or effect is it because they're
shut up shut indoors or did it cause it
in the first place so what are the
consequences of vitamin D deficiency
that are relevant to pain first of all
what's well very well established is
osteoporosis which is refers to the mass
of your bone structure osteomalacia
refers to but whether the bones are hard
or soft they're soft without you
Malaysia and pain is associated with
that muscle weakness is a very important
issue with vitamin D deficiency and I
want to I'm going to tell you more about
that shortly cartilage loss there's some
early evidence on that whether you can
maintain cartilage better if you have
enough vitamin D which would of course
help to reduce pain of osteoarthritis
for instance and is there a direct
effect on nerves we that I put that in
smaller print and with question marks
because the evidence for it is in the
early stages for sure now what are the
symptoms and signs of vitamin D
deficiency first of all stiffness these
are these are these are symptoms that
you might say are symptoms of old age
feeling aches and pains muscle and bone
pain although it can be very severe much
more severe than just the average a
campaign
muscle weakness it can be a grip that's
that's weak or getting out of the chair
let the time to get out of the chair is
related there have been some studies
showing that the longer it takes of a
person to get out of the chair and the
harder it is the lower their vitamin D
levels problems climbing stairs and I
can give you a perfect example of this
about women who how was climbing the
stairs on her hands and knees and was
losing the losing power her her
physicians did a an MRI of her spine to
see if she had a spinal cord tumor or
something like that but she didn't have
when she was tested her 25 hydroxy D
level was 7 nanomoles per liter one set
one tenth of what the lower end of the
range is within two weeks of taking
several thousand units of B per day she
was able to walk up the stairs sideways
not her quadriceps muscles were not
strong enough yet to let her go up front
with frontwards but she could just held
on his about so on to being railing for
balance and that that much power had
come back into her legs stress fractures
of course are related to osteoporosis
and that will be a sign and neuropathic
pain again I put that in with a question
mark
now the first study I want to present to
you was done in Denmark and published
actually in 2000 what they were trying
to do was to investigate myopathy
weakness of muscle in relation to
vitamin D status and they wanted to see
what happened when people with muscular
effects from vitamin D deficiency were
treated and then they were tested again
and they were trying to also see whether
the relationship of low vitamin D
myopathy to alkaline phosphatase testing
ALP 8lp test what it was because that
has been commonly used as a marker for
or low vitamin D bone problems so I took
first of all there were two state phases
to it they took eight patients who had
osteomalacia we had pain in there
because of low vitamin D and they did an
isokinetic dynamometer test of all their
major muscle groups before and after
three months of vitamin D treatment and
they showed that the biggest improvement
in muscle power employed in the
weight-bearing
anteye-gravity muscles of the lower
limbs in other words primarily the
quadriceps and then they went to the
next phase where they had 55 vitamin D
deficient failed women living in Denmark
and 22 Danish controls is the way to
express it and they did this same
testing they had done on the other ones
they tested on the quadriceps muscle not
this time only the quadriceps they
tested the maximal voluntary contraction
just how much effort they could make
have what the strength was of the
contracting the muscle and then they did
some electrical stimulation testing and
except some other some other parameters
then they treated them with high-dose
vitamin D and retested after three
months and six months after the treat
the they tested it retested them all the
the pre vitamin D before vitamin D all
the parameters of muscle function in the
deficient group were significantly lower
than the Danish controls you can see
that they have the p-value with
five-year-olds and another one with 4-0
they found that muscle function affected
to similar degree in the case with in
cases with or without bone involvement
as indicated by the elevated L AP and
when they measure the improvement post
treatment all the muscle related
parameters improved significantly after
three months and after six months only
the MDC was reduced compared with the
controls and here that significance had
dropped
we way down so there was a big
improvement this they concluded it in
this with this study that's having
muscle weakness with low vitamin D was a
prominent symptom of deficiency and that
severely impaired muscle function could
be present before you see any change any
any lab change in bone indicating bone
disease they felt that you had to give
the vitamin D for treat high-dose
treatment for six months or more to
fully normalize this don't forget that
three months they weren't completely
normalized and they said that these
serum levels of ALP when useless for
screening for this myopathy and 25
hydroxy D was the only reliable test but
you better watch out because you don't
want to overdo it which seems to be the
case with this fellow now I want to show
you the first study that caught my
attention that was published in the
British Medical Journal in 2004 this was
not a high level study this was a
descriptive study but it's so the
information that is so revealing that I
think you can see why I caught my
interest
they were looking at musculoskeletal
pain in female asylum seekers living in
Switzerland and they were relating it to
low levels of vitamin D so they had
these loving women they were this is a
range of their ages from 20 up to 62
they were from countries where it was
common to be covered they've been in
Switzerland the shortest time was one
year 11 was the longest they was over
only two who were not veiled not
covering their faces you know what I
want to draw to your attention is that
their pain complaints were fairly
ordinary they had pain in their ribs or
neck their low back they had shoulder
pain
so on one had complained of fatigue one
one had complained of weakness now
here's here's how they were diagnosed
well a lot of them weren't diagnosed low
back pain is not a diagnosis neither in
fact a name is chronic back pain but
somatoform disorder is a diagnosis and
you can see there are three with that
diagnosis and diagnosis and that's
saying that it's psychological saying
that someone has low back pain with a
functional component is just about the
same thing there's only one case where
the correct diagnosis was made which was
osteomalacia and here you'll see why
this is showing the diagnosis and in
nanograms per milliliter an animals per
liter what the what the blood levels
were in nanograms was one point eight to
six point four eight or four point five
to sixteen point two keeping in mind
what I said before below 25 is rickets
and these people were extremely low now
when you look at in this group how long
we had the symptoms it went from well
there was one that was only two months
but the average is about three years and
the time that it took to respond to
treatment was in turn this is measured
in months
it was around I don't know two and a
half months or three months something
like that and this is just showing their
blood levels again and the calcium we
there was one that they didn't have
calcium for but the other two other
levels of calcium were normal now this
is a study to show because wow how
frequently do we see this kind of thing
and this is one of the this was a health
survey for England and this is English
adults over 65 years and old over they
had just over 2000 of them living in the
community and they measured all their
blood levels and pain status and all
these kinds of things and they found
that symptoms of moderate to extreme
pain which were present in
3% of the sample we're associated with
poor vitamin D status independent of
other covariance this other one I want
to show you with this is a cohort of
white English people who've been
followed since the I think it's 1950s
and every few years they go back and
look at the making and this was where
they were looking at chronic widespread
pain which would be another term for
fibromyalgia they're the same criteria
they found in that large sample which
was almost 7,000 people that in the man
it was over 11 percent in women 12 and a
half percent of people had chronic
widespread pain and in the case of the
women with chronic widespread pain you
can in the orange here comparing them to
the women who did not have chronic
widespread pain there was a
statistically significant difference so
if they were more likely to have it if
they had Movida Mandi you'll notice that
the they always efficient because the
the mean the average for the groups was
all--just they were in in the low
fifties so they were it's surprising
that you can actually pick out a
difference with so when they're all that
low and now here's another study that I
found very interesting I wanted to make
that make the point that there's
specificity of themes with nonspecific
skeletal pain there seems to be a little
bit of specificity in terms of how
likely you are to be deficient depending
on where the pain is so we had 276
patients with nonspecific skeletal pain
they had 202 matched controls they
considered below 15 animals or that's 20
nanograms that was deficient and they
had pain all over the place
leg you know joints arthralgia rib pain
and so on and what they found was that
the mean 25 hydroxy D level was lower in
the group with pain that's that's seems
to be is extremely
significant and the proportion of
individuals who had deficiency was
significantly higher in the pain group
63% of them compared to 36 percent and
that was compared to the controls at
only 36 percent and there was a
significantly positive association
between the blood level and the skeletal
pain was and the odds ratio was two
point nine four and you'll see the
p-values very significant to college
that I see these numbers jumped around
when they were mounted on this program
what I found interesting here was the
odds ratio of having a low D was over
seven times higher if the pain was in
the leg which goes along with our study
on the large muscles of the legs like
the quadriceps and joint pain it was off
for about four times more likely to be
just you were four times more likely to
be the decision if you had joint pain
widespread pain it's almost a three and
they found a greater positive
association in women compared with men
it was about twice as as bigger list
they ought but then this group they said
there was no association with that pain
and fibromyalgia so of course she won't
be surprised to know that I'm now going
to show you a study on fibromyalgia and
this this one came from Saudi Arabia
last year it's not an Iran demised trial
or anything but and it's the only 30
women but it was very carefully done and
they were trying to see what the
prevalence was in a vitamin D deficiency
was among patients with fibromyalgia and
it was in a neurology clinic in Saudi
Arabia it's thirty females and they had
a very new they were using a new tool to
measure the pain they had something
called the widespread pain index and the
system severity score and they were very
carefully measuring things so here you
see a
to show you this because this is the the
mean the average and in nanograms per
milliliter it was four point seven six
and in animals eleven point nine it's so
low it's frightening and here three the
range was three to nine point three
seven point five to twenty three point
five and they retested them they test
them before the treatment and after
treatment and they did his widespread
pain index part once the te braking
refresh cognition and so on and
everything improves post treatment you
can see that it needs statistical
significance except for cognition and
when you look at these what they say
about that
they said that lack of improvement in
cognition is suggested to be related to
quote the fact that fibromyalgia
patients have significantly less total
total gray matter volume and three point
three times greater age associated
decrease in gray matter than healthy
controls as reported in peer-reviewed
journals now true this is a small group
there's no control group there's only 30
subjects and there's not not enough
detail for some people and sure but the
levels are alarmingly low and I think
that that's a red flag for everybody to
feel that we have to check people who
have fibromyalgia and get them get their
vitamin D levels up I then of course
found a study finally last year I've
been looking for years on back pain and
this was published in the Journal of
orthopedic surgery last year and it's on
it's relating the 25 hydroxy levels to
failed back surgery syndrome so people
had to have had particular screw and rot
instant instrumentation for yet they've
had a a really you know typical fusion
their visual on analog scale
it's the over six and they were using a
functional disability scale from Japan
the Japanese orthopedic Association JOA
score under ten what indicates
disability that they were was enough for
this study and the blood levels had to
be of vitamin D had to be below 70 which
is below 30 in Nana vans Familia and
they found they found people they had
nine subjects six men three women and
they were almost 40 years old they're
back their visual analog scale out of
ten they're paying was seven point seven
and their function was seven point six
where it should have been above ten when
their blood was tested their mean 25
hydroxy level was forty two point five
animals for leaders which is seventeen
nanograms per milliliter they had all
had intensive treatment with medications
and also things like psychological kinds
of treatments and for a minimum of six
months they tried everything they had
had a mean number of reoperation 2.21
the range was one to four and the main
duration of paying was two point six
years but it went up to five with
somebody with five and at leat the
minimum was a year and a half and what
they did was they brought controls which
they called indirect reference they were
age and disease matched and they had had
good outcomes from surgery you know
almost the same age their visual analog
scale showed that they had almost zero
either zero or only one out of ten teen
and their function was was really good
it was fourteen point seven on the JOA
scale
and their vitamin D was a mean of 100
and one or foreign animals or 40
milligrams and the range went from 70 to
145 so that were 28 to 58 so there was
nobody below the 70
cutoff point they treated them with
vitamin D 220 thousand international
units per day for ten days that's a goal
Calcifer all which is not as potent as
vitamin d3 and then the if it didn't
they retested them for after ten days
and it if it didn't go out they they
they kept giving them more until they
got to a normal level then they put them
on vitamin d3 600 international units
for matron maintenance which is the IOM
what the IOM recommends and they were
followed up at three months and six
months and you can see the levels went
up smartly from the baseline list this
is the in animals per meter for forty
two and a half well justjust let's just
say forty two because the test isn't as
active in assess up to 74 in three
months that's good up to 106 in in six
months then they tested their pain
scores the blue is the visual analog
scale which started at seven point seven
it was higher than the seven point six
and anyway after three months that had
dropped to five point two and then down
to four point two at six months and this
is only with vitamin D I'm not getting
anything else their function went from
7.6 on that JOA scale
they were already within three months
they were higher than the cutoff point
for their getting in the study it they
were at ten point two and they ended up
at eleven point one and they may
significance was point zero zero one
this was a improvement with only vitamin
D here's another study that brings up an
interesting point
these are 200 and this is published in
pain medicine a few years ago 2008 267
chronic pain patients that who were
admitted to a tertiary referral medical
center they called inadequate
25 hydroxy d2b less than 75 animals and
only I'm surprised in a way only 26%
were below 75 I would have thought it
would have been more than that they also
did a short form 36 health status
questionnaire and here's what I want to
show you one